political correctness oh yes which i
think is completely running rampant
across America and I live within it as
an academic as an academic to swim in it
all right so you know all right so let's
start there there so to the college part
of this you know Jerry Seinfeld about a
month ago Jerry Seinfeld who's the most
8 political comics I know everything
about Jerry Seinfeld I don't know any of
his political beliefs I have no idea if
he's for abortion for the death penalty
nobody has any idea what he thinks he
now is saying that college campuses have
gone to politically correct politically
correct Chris Rock has backed him on
this you know a whole bunch of comedians
have said this what is going on on
college campuses I'll give you a
powerful personal anecdote last year I
gave a talk at Wellesley College in all
women's college about the thought police
and how it regulates the free exchange
of ideas after my lecture a student came
up to me and said I don't think there's
anything wrong with the idea of a
professor at the start of class polling
a hundred students about how you should
address them so even though for example
Dave Rubin is my student I clearly see
you as a male at the start of every
lecture I should say do you do you
gender identify as male or female
because that will deter so I looked at
her and in true astonishment I said do
you really see this as a viable way by
which society would be organized where
every single time we interact we should
first preempt any any greeting with what
do yourself identify as and she said
absolutely because that way you wouldn't
be hurting anybody by placing them in
the wrong category yeah that's
astonishing right ok so what's the most
dangerous part of that because to me it
seems like let's say you went ahead and
did that you taught this class exactly
as sort of the social justice warriors
would want you to teach it well the
world doesn't operate like that right so
then are you actually then setting up
these kids these college kids for a huge
awakening where the day they graduate
college but they're not well trained to
face that real world right right
they are so tentative and the way they
express themselves right they're so
afraid to step outside the herd I mean
if you look at intellectual diversity on
campuses which is very much related to
what we're talking about it's
breathtaking right look I'm Canadian so
I don't care Republican or Democrat I
don't have a
that's right right but there are
stopping I gotta get this straight Jew
harab Canadian man 80s and brown skin
oh my you really do
so so there were studies that were done
looking at the political affiliations of
professors at major American
universities whether they're Republican
or Democrats and the numbers are just
astonishing and they get worse and worse
in terms of the ratio as a function of
the softness of the field sort of and
the humanities and sociology and Gender
Studies it's something like forty one
forty four to one
the ratio of now for some issues
political political lens doesn't matter
but for others as the death penalty
appropriate what should be our fiscal
policy should we should we be foreign
policy interventionist well your
political if lens affects these
discussions and to have all academia
being represented by one side of the
political spectrum is horrifying so what
do we do about that I mean even though I
may in most cases agree with that end of
academia not certainly not the political
correct side but I might agree with them
philosophically on a lot of the points
how do you balance that out what so
Thomas solo who's a very famous
conservative economist said I'm going to
botch the exact quote he said
intellectual diversity is diversity on
campuses is great as long as its sexual
orientation diversity ethnic diversity
racial diversity but the one diversity
that should really matter intellectual
diversity weak and M it well what we
need to do is rely on which is thought
exactly and what we need to do is to
find ways to create greater diversity on
campuses to allow both sides of any
position to speak yeah